in essence binomial events are a
sequence of identical Bernoulli events
before we get into the differences in
similarities between these two
distributions let us examine the proper
notation for a binomial distribution we
use the letter B to express a binomial
distribution followed by the number of
trials and the probability of success in
each one
therefore we read the following
statement as variable X follows a
binomial distribution with ten trials
and a likelihood of 0.62 succeed on each
individual trial additionally we can
express a Bernoulli distribution as a
binomial distribution with a single
trial all right to better understand the
differences between the two types of
events suppose the following scenario
you go to class and your professor gives
the class a suprise pop quiz which you
have not prepared for luckily for you
the quiz consists of 10 true or false
questions in this case guessing a single
true or false question is a Bernoulli
event but guessing the entire quiz is a
binomial event alright let's go back to
the quiz example we just mentioned in it
the expected value of the Bernoulli
distribution suggests which outcome we
expect for a single trial now the
expected value of the binomial
distribution would suggest the number of
times we expect to get a specific
outcome great now the graph of the
binomial distribution represents the
likelihood of attaining our desired
outcome a specific number of times if we
run n trials our graph would consist n
plus 1 many bars one for each unique
value from 0 to n for instance we could
be flipping the same unfair coin we had
from the last lecture if we toss it
twice we need bars for the three
different outcomes 0 1 or 2 tails
fantast
if we wish to find the Associated
likelihood of getting a given outcome a
precise number of times over the course
of n trials we need to introduce the
probability function of the binomial
distribution for starters each
individual trial is a Bernoulli trial so
we express the probability of getting
our desired outcome as P and the
likelihood of the other one as one minus
P in order to get our favorite outcome
exactly why many times over the N trials
we also need to get the alternative
outcome n - why many times if we don't
account for this we would be estimating
the likelihood of getting our desired
outcome at least why many times
additionally more than one way to reach
our desired outcome could exist to
account for this we need to find the
number of scenarios in which Y out of
the N many outcomes would be favorable
but these are actually the combinations
we already know for instance if we wish
to find out the number of ways in which
four out of the six trials could be
successful it is the same as picking
four elements out of a sample space of
six now you see why combining Toric's
are a fundamental part of probability
thus we need to find the number of
combinations in which Y out of the n
outcomes would be favorable for instance
there are three different ways to get
tails exactly twice in three coin flips
therefore the probability function for a
binomial distribution is the product of
the number of combinations of picking Y
many elements out of n times P to the
power of Y times 1 minus P to the power
of n minus y great to see this in action
let us look at an example imagine you
bought a single stock of General Motors
historically you know there is a 60%
chance the price of your stock will go
up on any given day and a 40% chance it
will drop by the price going up we mean
that the closing price is higher than
the
opening price with the probability
distribution function you can calculate
the likelihood of the stock price
increasing three times during the five
workday week if we wish to use the
probability distribution formula we need
to plug in 3 for y 5 for n and point 6
for P after plugging in we get number of
different possible combinations of
picking three elements out of five times
point six to the power of three times
0.4 to the power of two this is
equivalent to 10 times point two one six
times point one six or point three four
five six thus we have a 34 point five
six percent chance of getting exactly
three increases over the course of a
workweek
the big advantage of recognizing the
distribution is that you can simply use
these formulas and plug in the
information you already have all right
now that we know the probability
function we can move on to the expected
value by definition the expected value
equals the sum of all values in the
sample space multiplied by their
respective probabilities the expected
value formula for a binomial event
equals the probability of success for a
given value multiplied by the number of
trials we carry out after computing the
expected value we can finally calculate
the variance we do so by applying the
short formula variance of y equals the
expected value of y squared minus the
expected value of y squared
after some simplifications this results
in n times P times 1 minus P if we plug
in the values from our stock market
example that gives us a variance of five
times point six times 0.4 or one point
two this would give us a standard
deviation of approximately one point one
knowing the expected value and the
standard deviation allows us to make
more accurate future forecasts
if you found this video interesting and
want to gain an edge in your career make
sure to LIKE comment and subscribe
and don't forget to check out some of
our other videos for another quick win
in the data science skills department